Jeff where does the truth line in
between are they both correct in some
way I think it lies a lot more on
Giancarlo Stanton side than it does
Derek Jeter's and the problem is Derek
Jeter won't acknowledge the fact that he
played this wrong from the beginning
when a guy like Giancarlo Stanton has a
no-trade clause it's something that
hangs over every transactional
possibility there is in Derek Jeter I
think could have really smooth this over
and made this process a whole lot easier
if at the beginning he had called up
Giancarlo Stanton said listen this is
where we're at this is what we're
thinking we want to work with you
instead it became an adversarial process
and when you when you buy a team for 1.2
billion dollars and don't make one of
your first phone calls to the guy you
owe nearly 300 million dollars over the
next 10 years
that implicitly says you are not in our
plans for the future and so when you
don't involve him in that I think it led
to the Animus that was involved in this
situation and it ended up with Giancarlo
Stanton striking away those deals to the
Giants and the Cardinals and becoming a
new york' so let's let's follow the the
line of thinking here that you just
posited there Jeff do you think that
Jeter had he worked with Stanton could
have created a market between the four
teams that that Stanton gave him a list
that he would have traded been all
allowed himself to be traded to say the
Dodgers in the Yankees bidding against
one another or did they not at all walk
me through that part of this process
well let's put it this way I think what
ended up happening is because Jeter went
out immediately and started talking to
the 14 that Stanton wanted to go to
potentially the those teams knew that
there was no leverage that they could
wield in that situation those teams saw
that okay if the Marlins right now do
want to get rid of him
they have no compelling reason to ask
for something small but when when
Giancarlo Stanton rejected the Giants
and Cardinals that gave the opportunity
to the
Yankees say okay well we know that you
are up a creek without a paddle right
now and that we're going to be able not
to offer Estevan Oriol not to offer
champ Adams not to offer Clint Fraser
but to offer a much lesser prospect and
that that is ultimately what happened
and you know it Jorge Guzman may be a
really good pitcher in the long run he
throws extremely hard but he's also a 22
year old who hasn't pitched above short
season a ball uh endeavors Jose Nevers
maybe you know maybe he fills out a
little bit it becomes a real short stuff
but the idea that you're trading an MVP
and getting that little back
aside from salary salary really really
shows where the Marlins thinking was in
this situation and here's one thing I
don't blame Derek Jeter one bit for
trading John Carlos damn I think that
actually is the right mood for where the
Marlins are but if you're going to start
tearing it down by trading stamp and by
trading Gordon you need to trade Marcell
Ozuna we need to trade Christian Yelich
and even consider trading JT Realmuto
and need to really burn this thing to
the ground and I'll see you know I'm
curious to see what happens with the
Marlins over the next few years because
it's gonna get ugly it's going to get
lean but if they can buy down some of
that debt that they have with these low
payrolls
and potentially stock up on prospects
all of a sudden we've got a future that
looks a little bit better I just like to
see Derek Jeter if not acknowledge the
fact that he might have made a mistake
or Mis played this then at least in the
future say hey it was early on in my job
I didn't quite understand the
circumstances of the situation
I now know better and that that's why
I'm not judging Derek Jeter long-term at
this point that the short term rich has
been as ugly as it can get Jeff Passan
of Yahoo Sports joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get to the larger
picture then if baseball is having a
renaissance in the the
in the following okay Cubs break their
their jinx in their streak and and they
finally win but you also have the Astros
and the Royals when in the World Series
along with the Giants in the last couple
of years right and why would they
baseball want to have as a narrative a
team that is just selling everything off
why would they allow a team to be
purchased when they clearly are look
there apparently looking for I read on
your site on your article a quarter of a
million dollars may be of more funding
why would baseball a lot of a billion
billion right quarter of a billion
dollars why would they allow this trade
to go through period if they knew that
the person is buying it potentially is
gonna burn it down to the ground to try
and and make their money back why would
baseball go through with this I think
there are two answers to that question
the first we need to look back at what
Major League Baseball's motivations were
here Jeffrey Loria was the worst owner
in baseball for a long time and that's
saying something when Frank McCourt was
an owner and Major League Baseball okay
and and I think that I think major
league baseball saw Derek Jeter as as
this paragon of virtue and somebody who
has been successful in all walks of life
and who survived New York for 20 years
with nary a bad word being said about
him and in their calculus was that if
Derek Jeter can be an owner of this team
he's going to bring a measure of class
respectability and and just altogether
competence otherwise that they haven't
had their in a long time and that's what
has shaken officials in MLB right now
they're looking at this and they're
saying to themselves what the hell have
we gotten into Jorge Maas was there to
buy the Marlins he's a guy who is a
Miami native who has ties in the
community who really could have repaired
the relationships that inside of Miami
have just been torched by Lauria but
jorge mas also saw something and that
was the Marlins books and their
financials are an absolute disaster
and he said I'm not gonna pay 1.2
billion dollars for this so in Major
League Baseball's eyes getting a billion
- for the Marlins and getting Derek
Jeter was better than getting a guy who
long-term probably would have been the
right person to own that team they were
taking a risk in going with their
cheater and and it's a risk that at this
point has not paid off yet and that
they're hoping can be salvaged but the
big question about their Jeter let's
remember at the end of his career when
he was a bad shortstop Jeter still
thought he was really good at the end of
his career when he did not belong in the
two hole in the Yankees lineup he still
believed that he was a two hole hitter
he and that is part of what made him
such a great player it was just this
blind faith that you are going to be
great and I still think he see that but
ownership is a lot different than being
a major league baseball player the skill
set
it requires human touch it requires the
ability to glad-hand it requires all the
things that their shooter frankly
disdained as a player so he needs to
learn that he needs to acknowledge that
yes maybe this has been a little bit
overwhelming at the beginning but
there's room to learn to grow and to
become the type of owner that I think
he's capable of being so then the last
question for you Jeff Passan of Yahoo
Sports calling in from from the Winter
Meetings is now baseball is left with
the narrative the old the old narrative
which blows up the narrative that they
have been so good at at broadcasting
that that that the mid-market teams have
a shot now you've got the rich getting
richer with Giancarlo Stanton but you do
take a look at the roster and the reason
why they're able to pay him all that
money and put them in there is they have
all these young players that haven't had
to get their big large contracts yet I
mean they've really grown from the
grassroots up very well with a ton of
prospects what is the next Yankee moves
I've already seen one today would chase
headley being sold off to San Diego
which suddenly appears to be a
in the mix quite a bit here in this
Winter Meetings what do you think the
next moves the domino effect of this
trade is going to be Jeff you know it
opens up a lot of possibilities for them
because they want to get under the
luxury tax pissing and there's a big
reason for that right now they're paying
upward of 50 cents on the dollar for
every dollar they're over the luxury tax
threshold if they go and get under it
this season that resets their number and
they're paying only 20 cents on the
dollars so we're talking about tens of
millions of dollars in savings
potentially for when they go out next
offseason and really pursue Manny
Machado and the idea of a lineup with
Manny Machado didi Gregorius flavor
Torrez and Greg Bird around the diamond
with Gary Sanchez behind home plate and
and with Clint Frazier Giancarlo Stan
and Aaron judge in the outfield I mean
we're talking about a potentially
historic lineup right there and all the
Yankees need is some pitching right now
in the the Headley deal clears 13
million dollars off that luxury tax
number because San Diego took on every
penny of that contract and it gives them
the ability if they want to go out and
to get in Alex Cobb or to be in play
potentially free Yu Darvish or a Jake
Arrieta or bring CC Sabathia back
they're also in play with some young
controllable starters whether it's
Michael Fullmer Gerrit Cole so they have
a lot of irons in the fire right now and
they're they're probably world series
favorites for a reason at this point and
that's not selling the Astros short
that's not buying the Cubs of the
Dodgers short it's just that the Yankees
have an array of talent that's probably
right now unmatched throughout the game
Jeff thanks for the call appreciate it
we'll chat with you down Ilan pleasure
is always mine right Jonathan about a
great column Jeff pass and read it the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience